on va essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé avec ce procès fantôme avec le
criminaliste jean claude hébert bonsoir
jean claude
mas procès fantôme c'est à dire son
numéro de dossier un juge qui n'a pas vu
les témoins qui n'a pas vu l'accusé qui
n'a même pas siéger dans une salle de
cours qui ne laissait donc aucune trace
avez vous déjà vu dans votre carrière
quelque chose comme ça
euh non non j'ai déjà entendu vaguement
parlé de procès à huis clos
par exemple en matière de
d'espionnage ou des choses comme ça mais
ce sont des cas extrêmement rare est
aussi
fermée que celui qu'on a connu récemment
jamais ce qui est à filtrer un petit peu
comme information mais vraiment ce ne
sont que des brides c'est que c'était
relié à une histoire d'indicateurs un
informateur finalement de la grc
quelqu'un qui risque sa vie s'il est
identifié
pour vous est-ce que c'est un argument
valable pour qu'on fasse un tel procès
fantôme qui ne laissent aucune trace
il y en a d'autres procès se déroule
assez régulièrement avec des
informateurs des indicateurs il y à des
mécanismes prévus pour permettre la
protection de ces gens là parce que ce
sont les gens qui n'ont pas
nécessairement beaucoup de vertus et qui
sont nécessaires pour le travail
policier et fait en sorte qu'on puisse
attraper les têtes dirigeantes du crime
organisé c'est le cas parce que
évidemment
sont plus difficiles à récuser donc la
plus utilisée je dirais pas
régulièrement merci ah si quand même
souvent ce genre d'intervention doit
d'avoir des libertés - où on appelle ça
des faits - repent cible le mot au mois
est mal choisi ce sont plus et fait
moins mercenaires mais on accepte
parfois de leur donner les avantages et
des sommes d'argent même assez
substantiel un léchage de leur
collaboration pour attraper les gens qui
sont plus haut dans la pyramide oui mais
par contre si jamais se retrouve à
procès on n'a jamais vu ou jamais
entendu parlé de procès fantôme de cette
source à dire qu'on peut protéger leur
identité on peut faire un huis clos on
peut avoir d ordonnance de
non-publication message va jamais aussi
loin que ce qu'on a vu dans cette
histoire de procès fantôme par les noms
vous avez raison mais sont violés ici
parce que même l'accusé a quelque part
voit ses propres droits à risque si ça
laisse des traces tonnes par
ben oui parce que et coûté 1,1 point à
celle d'abord avec les systèmes qu'on a
c'est enregistré 1 tout ce qui se dit
peut être transcrit mensuellement et que
ce soit une partie où l'eau ils se
plaignent évidemment de la façon avec
laquelle on a procédé peut démontrer un
tribunal de révision
tribunal d'appel
avec les transcriptions qu'effectivement
il ya des gens qui ont commis des
maladresses des erreurs et on demande de
réparation on a donc de la preuve
matérielle
documentés où pouvoir s'expliquer ici
lorsque la cour d'appel si on suit à la
mémoire de ceux qui ont participé à ce
procès là pour raconter
finalement l'histoire au tribunal de
révision ce qui est assez exceptionnel
et surtout on n'a pas vraiment une image
réaliste de ce qui s'est fait et de ses
fils il dit
comment vous envisagé qu'un juge ait pu
accepter de mener à procès de faire un
jugement dans de telles conditions
c'est étonnant parce que la décision
appartient au juge une partie un témoin
peuvent repérer dick est d'avoir une
protection suffisante pour la sécurité
du témoin par exemple mais finalement le
jus je doit exercer son équilibre ce
christ ionnaires et dire quels sont les
avantages tels sont les inconvénients et
parmi les inconvénients vous en avez
énuméré quelques-uns y en a plusieurs
mais y'a pas uniquement cela il ya le
public le droit du public d'être
renseigné sur ce qui se passe dans une
salle d'audience et on sait très bien
que souvent le public renseigné parce
que les médias sont présents dans la
salle seoul décrire ce qui s'est passé
hélas si personne n'était au courant de
ce qui se passe parce qu'on se cache en
quelque part je ne sais trop où comment
voulez vous communiquer l'information au
public qu'ils puissent évaluer ce qui
s'est passé là il dit ces terres il ou
encore 5 septembre alors l'opinion
publique doit surveiller ce qui se passe
dans une salle de justice pour s'assurer
que tout se passe dans la normalité mais
vous avez vu que le ministre de la
justice sinon je les barrettes à
demander des comptes en fait il veut
savoir il veut savoir qui est impliquée
là-dedans qui sont les avocats qui sont
juge qu est ce qui risque de se passer à
partir de maintenant une fois que les
noms vont être dévoilées est ce que ces
gens là qui ont été mêlés à ce procès
risque des sanctions est votre avis
et c'est
une des manches lors qu'ils auront un
surfer bon sens de la part du ministre
désire je vais demander à des procureurs
de faire une requête à la cour d'appel
pour que la cour d'appel autorise le des
caviardage des noms d'inonder les
abatteurs les noms du juge et si ces
temps l'intérêt public on en parlait à
quelques instants de divulguer les noms
en question et je vois pas comment on
les cache indéfiniment basques ont alors
on sera davantage de qui il s'agissait
et les organismes responsables le
barreau
le dpcp si il dans l'intérêt mais il
sans réussir ici que c'est le service
des poursuites fédérales qui était en
cause au intérêt à demander pourquoi ça
s'est passé comme ça et quelles étaient
les justifications au moins il y aura
quelqu'un quelque part qui va expliquer
pourquoi c'est arrivé est ce que le
conseil de la magistrature devrait s'en
mêler aussi
le conseil reste reçu un droit de regard
sur la conduite des juges alors
évidemment si quelqu'un en quelque part
vont l'accuser porter plainte contre le
juge pour ne pas avoir respecté les
données fondamentales de notre justice
effectivement le conseil de la
magistrature pouvoir d'examiner le
dossier ils de demander au juge de
s'expliquer et la réussite pour le motif
qu'ils n'auraient pas respecté son code
de déontologie par exemple bon alors
c'est vraiment un dossier à suivre ans
parce qu on a comme l'impression qu'on
ne franchit une ligne ici jean claude
hébert merci beaucoup pour vos
explications ce soir
merci au revoir au revoir